2020 Democratic frontrunner Joe Biden
facing major scrutiny for yet another
blunder made on the campaign trail this
time he's being accused of telling a
false war story while describing
security concerns and traveling to
war-torn Afghanistan when he was vice
president now Biden says he was trying
to honor a Navy captain who refused to
receive the Silver Star from him for his
heroism four-star general asked me
whether I'd go up into the Father now
everybody got concerned the vice
president going up in the middle of this
but there were we can lose a vice
president
we can't lose many more of these kids
not a joke this guy climbed down a
ravine carried this guy up on his back
under fire and the general wanted me to
pin the Silver Star on him I got up
there and Stannis the God's truth my
word as a Biden he stood his attention I
went to pin him I said sir I don't want
the damn thing do not put it on me sir
please sir do not do that he died The
Washington Post calling out Joe Biden
over that story saying the former VP
mixed up several events jumbling them
together to create a false narrative and
Biden pushing back on the controversy
and wondering what the big deal was I
was making the point how courageous
these people are how incredible they are
this generation of warriors these fallen
angels we've lost and so that I don't
know what the problem is I mean what is
it that I said wrong all right Lawrence
what do you make of all this I don't
think it's the lion I mean most people
will believe that politicians lie I
think that's kind of baked thin with the
voters they politicians just lie all the
time I do think there's something going
on with Biden
I mean he's lost a step I mean there's
one thing that gaffes but he could even
remember President Obama's name to other
day and he's just reserved to call him
his boss what makes this such a big
thing going into the next debate is that
these young people are going to start
the frame if they are willing to take
off the gloves they can make this
argument Biden is too old right he's too
old and you see that he's too old and so
it's just not about new ideas now it's
the matter can the president actually
remember intelligence right now when he
has to make it
if he goes to the / office and I think
Democrats are gonna have to have a
conversation about their electability
thing if your candidate cannot remember
things I don't think he can go on a
debate stage and defeat Donald Trump
well let's not attribute this gaffe
whatever it is to age because there are
a lot of people who are older than Joe
Biden who still got it going on and then
see see Greg and I we're season we're
season but Sir you think it was a head
injury no I'm saying that sometime when
you have a lot of information in your
brain and you try to put it out to mouth
it comes across like you jumble in the
story so but he did Rumble with oh he
jumble in it look the facts are there
okay but most people know Joe Biden's
character they know his value system
they know that he visited Iraq and
Afghanistan over 21 times as a United
States Senator and vice president but
this story the way it came across and it
came out heartfelt because people know
that Joe Biden his heartfelt that's why
I continue to touch him and I'll touch
you it touches a lot of people check in
on their to try to make a big deal out
of it but it might not hurt him well you
know what he tells a good story yeah
it's kind of like a child you know I was
president of Mars and we built the
balloon raft and we went to Australia
and I met lions and tigers and giraffes
and that I had rhubarb pie was the best
pie ever had that's my impression but
here's the problem it may not be that
funny because you can I think we could
end a presidency like that I'm not sure
you can start one you can't start a
presidency already kind of like slow and
I'm well I mean I like Joe Biden a lot
and if you if he leaves this race which
I think he will I do I do think he will
oh wow yeah then it's Fantasy Island
without mr. work or tattoo it's it's
basically all supporting cast and III I
think that if he leaves I don't know who
else is there but I just I see this I go
like this is there's there's something
else there that makes it so that the
joke isn't
funny and it's like he's not so much
driving new stories on his own like the
stories are driving him so stories about
all of these other things like he's not
out there making the news the news is
coming to him sure he's reacting to it
in that way what I find so disturbing as
a voter is the notion being put forth by
his defenders that were in some type of
post truth era that there's a spectrum
and that well it's not as bad as this so
it's okay
that his misstatements and misspeaks and
gaffes are not the same as quote you
know Trump's purposeful daily assaults
on the truth and well these are just
slips but what Trump does is a horribly
you know bending the truth and it's been
it's historically an assault all of
these things that to me as a voter I
deserve the truth all the time end of
story
period and I don't want my
commander-in-chief representing me in
international diplomacy negotiations
with someone that close he's gonna say
the wrong story is he gonna be called
out later and humiliated well one thing
I think Don I wanted to ask you about is
the Lawrences point so now we have the
upcoming debate you will only have ten
of them on stage it's the first time
that the three front three or four front
runners will be on stage together I have
a theory that Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders will not go after Joe Biden for
things like this I think they'll go
after him for his record like Kamala
Harris did in the first time but it
might with its Elizabeth Warren maybe
she goes after him for his cozy
relationship with the credit card
companies or something like that right
do you think that they're ready to sort
of take the gloves off against the
front-runner why should they take the
when you go when you go after Joe Biden
you're also going after Barack Obama in
the sense that you're attacking some of
the policies and some of the initiatives
of that administration that's what
happened in the last and so they'll go
back though to the 90s so perhaps they
will but I think that the most important
thing in this next debate some of the
candidates are still stuck in single
digits
they better figure out a way to get back
on the next stage and to use this
performance to really highlight why Joe
Biden can't continue to use President
Obama as a shield the reports say that
President Obama said Joe you don't have
to do this and that even President Obama
was concerned about Joe Biden destroying
the legacy
and so although President Obama may not
go on the attack there are plenty of
advisers out there that don't monitor I
mean but one thing I would say that Joe
Biden would be the only one on the stage
is actually defending the Obama
administration and everybody else is
saying it didn't go far enough left the
other the other issue is you gotta go
tough on Joe because trumpet will show
him no mercy
yeah you got you if you have a fighter
you're not gonna tell them to relax on
the beach when you're when you're facing
a steamroller most Americans know Joe
Biden like I said at the beginning they
know his values they see weakness yeah
if they see weakness you know what they
will try to take advantage of it but
people like you know but I mean people I
mean people they don't want to take from
Trump is you can win yeah there's no
sign of weakness when he's there when he
faces Biden if Biden is crushed no
matter how much you like him that's
right it's gonna be over and to your
point I think they know him but they're
not inspired by him maybe they like him
but they're not excited about him no one
is excited about him whatsoever so on
that stage everyone's going to attack
not only his policy but they're going to
be putting themselves on the offense of
look at me and how inspiring I am and
that's that's what's going to be
magnetic he's gonna lose what if he goes
on the offense during the debate and
that would be good and say what have you
done lately , yeah I was on the campaign
trail in Iowa with him and his campaign
is clearly trying to keep him away from
the public right he has a teleprompter
in front of him other candidates win him
to lobby to greet people at the Union
Joe went through the back door and so
the campaign realizes the people that
are opposed to protect Joe Biden that
there's a problem going on whether it's
memory or whatever it may be or he's
just lying and they don't want him out
there in front of the well he's getting
a lot of things wrong and it begs for
the concern but you know the king of
Lies is the person who's currently in
the White House or 12-thousand according
to the Washington Post so I think the
Vice President misspoke he got his facts
wrong
he got his story wrong but he's still I
think in the primary but you know thing
is in general that's word to you well
I'd say that Trump's lies aren't based
on any kind of mental
efficiency he's basically lying for us
right he always thinks that this night
this lie is going to help us in the long
run it's not because he's forgetful or
he's losing his faculties I you can hate
Trump all you want but you know when
he's up there
he knows what day it is no I'm not sure
that I would agree with that